good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this central area planning
committee meeting on july the 1st 2021
my name is councillor michael edwards
and i'm the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members the setup for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for kovid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
the 29th of april 2021
in the interest of membrane officer
safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and buying present in this meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up or raise your
paddle to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask put on your visor
turn on your microphone and speak
clearly please reference a page or
paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers keep
your contributions as clear and concise
as possible
and ensure your microphones remain off
when not speaking
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels
within the chamber and advised at the
far exit is the door
behind this top table
item two of only apologies for absence
and we've received apologies for absent
from councillor heard thank you chair
thank you item three minutes of the last
meeting on the 2nd of june 2021
these are found on pages 7 to 12 and it
is recommended that the minutes of that
meeting
are approved as a true and accurate
record i so move do i have a seconder
thank you councillor none if any member
wishes to speak on any matters of
accuracy
please indicate that you wish to speak
there are none can i agree can i uh
ask for agreement by ascent thank you
item 4 declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary
interests other vacunary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph six to
eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout this meeting
item four
planning application 21 stroke zero zero
oh
sorry i'll beg your pardon
thank you chair uh just a non-pecuniary
interest that i used to live in plume
avenue
thank you that's sweden
um a personal non-pecuniary interest in
item
five i'm not personally acquainted with
mr coxy but
he and i are both in my grandson's
fantasy football league
thank you countless women um agenda item
five then
planning application 21 stroke zero zero
three two six
has 38 plume avenue we moved to agenda
item five
these are pages 13 to 20 please note
that the members update in relation to
this application has been circulated
prior to this meeting ms king please can
you present your report
thank you chairman plan permission is
sought
for the construction of a two-story
front extension
two story side extension and single
story front
side and rear extensions
this is a location plan showing the
proposed site outlined in red
this is the existing block plan and the
proposed block plan
please note the shed is existing and is
to be retained
these the existing elevations
these are the proposed elevations
showing the front side and rear
extensions
this is the existing ground floor plan
and the existing first floor plan
and these are the proposed ground floor
plan
and the proposed first floor plan
this is a street scene showing the
proposed dwelling alongside the existing
neighbouring dwellings
and these are the photographs of the
site showing the existing front and rear
elevations of the dwelling please note
the shed cannot be seen above the
existing boundary wall
the application is recommended for
approval thank you chairman
thank you okay members
i open the debate and invite you to put
any questions or make any comments you
have on this report
councillor morris thank you mr chairman
um
i've looked at this report i think it's
um a very good report from the officer
and um i i'm in complete agreement i
think that um
this one is a gooden and uh i would
propose that we accept the officer's
report and
uh grant permission
is it going a second or for that
um
yes so it's going to be a bay window at
ground floor
and an extension to the front of the
garage as well
and see at the first floor the front
elevation will be
extended as well
thank you councilman councillor shawnee
you called this in would you like to
comment
so could i remind members to use their
microphones
thanks for the reminder sorry thank you
um
yes i was asked to call this in by mtc
planning committee as there was much
discussion about this at the time
and i know it says on the report that it
was passed by town
but it was only marginally passed by
town
and i was asked to call it in which
indeed i have
um now i referred
um to um d1 and h4 i'd like to just um
expand on those if i may jam and thank
you
d11b i think the
size and scale of this
is much too big for the original
property
and um it's it's out of proportion to
the emit uh
to the original property as well
um on h uh d14
um i think there is probably some
overlooking particularly to the houses
on wallace binder close
i think there is visual impact
all round it's a vast
extension on all sides of this
property and i think there
may be some daylight and sunlight issues
with any of the neighbors
as for h4 chairman thank you alterations
extensions or additions
um are supposed to maintain enhance the
character and sustainability
of the original building um and
on number two be of an appropriate scale
and i don't think this is of an
appropriate scale i think this
is um really unbalanced and and is very
over scale if there is uh such a
thing and
if i can draw people's attention to
5.2.5 on page 17 thank you chairman
the proposal to lower or alter the roof
style and i think this has recently
come in this alteration by 40
centimeters
does not really alter the bulk and scale
of this proposal at all
it still looks cramped within the plot
um to to quote um from that
um 5.2.5
um and it mentions number four it's
nowhere near
38. there are some individual properties
on that side at the top
here number four so it's not really
um sort of comparable at all
and i think it's very much
too near number 36 which is the um
building uh the property uh to the right
of 38. um i'll leave it at that for the
moment thank you chairman
thank you uh still
thank you mr chair first of all can i
ask the officer have there been
any letters of uh complaints against
this
application through your chair neither
hasn't
thank you i actually think that from the
pictures
that we've got the drawings that it
actually enhances
the front of the house and the street
scene it brings it in line with the one
next door to it
and there is quite gaps between those
those two houses
and if we can see the picture of the
back garden
you can actually see that they actually
have a very large back garden so they
aren't
overlooking the neighbor's gardens at
all
uh yeah thank you actually um i was
gonna ask for the photographs to be put
back up
um and also the side elevation um which
shows
quite a dense wall i just wanted to have
another look at
thank you so there's no there's no
windows
adjacent on the western elevation
um there are no windows that overlook
the house next
door is that where the small the very
small gap is
just through your chair yes okay thank
you
thank you mr chairman thank you very
good
thank you sorry that's right thank you
chair um
i i concur with uh councillor shawnee
because of of
the areas within the policies that she
cited d1 especially
um with bb in the height scale reform
the the street scene
there are some larger houses at the top
but the street seniors has houses that
are predominantly of the same type of
size
so the bulk and scan of this will be out
of proportion
and there again against the existing
street scene
at massing and again i concur with uh
point four of that policy uh about the
visual impact
i think it has a negative visual impact
and that one meter
gap although it may be legal is visually
upsetting
uh within relation to the balance of the
street scene
thank you thank you thank you
uh yeah could could i have another look
at the street scene please
thank you
are there any photographs of the street
street
scene all right okay
thank you
okay okay thank you
uh can't just wait
thank you chairman um i think i can
see from that the projection further of
the garage
out will still be um which we say
behind or in line with the next door
because the house itself is set
further back isn't it um
also along that road um
almost every house has done some sort of
extension development at the front
38 so an extension
there is sort of them slightly diverging
from the line of
the the next door house that's on the
left-hand side
so that is sort of less less of an
intrusion than it would be if the houses
weren't directly in
parallel with each other for next week
thank you well we have a proposal by
councillor morris
to approve this seconded by cancer raise
um can we go to the vote on this
voting in favor of the recommendation
recorded vote please chair
recorded right please
thank you chairman members i will call
your names in alphabetical order we're
voting for
councillor mars proposal seconded by
councillor mays to approve the
application
in line with the officer's
recommendation starting counselor beal
four councillor edwards four
councillor hubner four
councillors councillor mays
paul councillor morris
obviously four councillor nan
or councillor seancy against
thank you members that's eight for the
proposal
two against no abstentions that's
carried in thank you very much
um item six any items of business i have
none
therefore believe it or not i close this
meeting
at 7 45 as a record
you